this great big story was made possible
by ibm
every child is a scientist and just like
everywhere in the world every child in
africa is very curious likes to
experiment likes to discover
imagine
every single student on the african
continent
having their own science lab with the
microscopes and then the circuit boards
and carrying that science lab with them
everywhere they go
i'm chaos of oriantepim i'm 26 years old
i'm a scientist and some people call me
the mad scientist
he might be mad but he sure is brilliant
to tackle the lack of science education
in ghana charles and his team took a
science lab and just kind of shrunk it
back in 2015 my co-founder michael and i
really wanted to find a solution and
that was when we built the first
prototype for the sunset
the sunset is a lab
that is small enough that it can fit on
the desk of a student
and affordable enough that every student
can simply have one the sign set
currently costs 20
it has close to 45 individual components
inside it
and the students can use to perform a
wide variety of activities
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
or anything in the sciences to make
anything that can help people
i use it to
do my homework you can use it to make us
something like
a security detector an alarm
one of the really exciting things that
we've seen is when you give students
access to these tools and then they
understand the concepts really well
these students begin to innovate
one of such examples is a student called
princess she didn't have access to
electricity after using the sciences and
network electrical circuit she came up
with her light box and now four of her
friends can come to a house and they can
collaborate on their homework
while the dream is big for this mad
scientist up next is something actually
pretty small we are creating a
microscope that costs us the last five
dollars the idea for the microscope is
to be able to use really affordable uh
materials to be able to create something
that can magnify up to about 10x to 45x
so the students can view onion cells and
things like that
it's humbling i would say it feels very
humbling to see students use their sign
set we believe that they're not to this
in the future you're going to have
really really awesome scientists coming
from africa
[Music]
you